[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000. as always my name is caleb denby
and i will be your driver on this
journey
um tonight is sort of a bittersweet
night it's potentially the final road
2000 on tuesday nights um my class is
actually switching with beginner
breakdown which generally takes place on
monday nights
so in this normal time slot next week
you can expect to see the wonderful alex
mullering teaching you some more of
those wonderful basics
i'll be moving to monday nights
hopefully most weeks we can still get
that online although especially with the
upcoming rapid and blitz tournament uh
who's new merch i'm repping um we're
gonna have a lot going on at the chess
club so looking forward to it um tonight
i wanted to talk about something kind of
fun um and i think there are still some
lessons that we can draw from it i want
to talk about some of the most famous
odds games in recent memory so of course
what is an odds game uh it's a game
where one player is pretty clearly
stronger than the other player so to try
to make it a little bit more fair they
give them some kind of odds either peace
odds or you know time odds is especially
common these days especially for you
know like hustlers trying to play blitz
so to start with i want to talk about
one of the games from the king of odds
givers paul
morphy
so of course paul morphy played a lot of
opponents that he was head and shoulders
better than uh and so to make it a
little bit more fun oftentimes he would
give them odds
uh so let's just start with this one
on the board here we see that uh paul's
victim in this case theodore knight a
good chess name theodore knight uh is up
a full rook and a knight uh paul morphy
is starting without either of these
pieces and so i kind of want to go
through see if we can put ourselves in
theodore knights shoes and paul morphy's
shoes see if we can create chances and
and defend against them so
uh i really like paul's opening choice
here morphy's opening choice you get e4
e5 and the king's gambit so this is a
really great opening choice because
oftentimes white will attack straight
out of the opening in an opening like
the king's gambit and these two pieces
sometimes never even get
find the time to get involved so maybe
he won't be missing those here
knight accepts the gauntlet takes on f4
and we get knight f3
g5 and bishop c4
so already i kind of want to say pretty
terrible practical play by by theodore
knight if if someone is giving you odds
and they play something like the king's
gambits uh really all you want to do is
get your extra pieces into the game once
your extra pieces are playing in the
game they really shouldn't be able to
just walk all over you because you you
have more pieces than them so while this
is normal king's gambit uh quote-unquote
theory you know taking the pawn and
holding on to it with g5
against someone who's already down a
rook and a knight probably it's a little
bit better just to develop so out of
curiosity
uh are you guys familiar with ways that
black can can develop rather quickly
against the king's gambit maybe what
line should mr knight have have chosen
yeah the the faulkner counter gamut is a
great one so uh as usual against uh
these tricky gambits in one e4 e5 black
can very very often either give some
material back or at least just find this
nice freeing move with d5
the nice thing about e4 e5 is both sides
have played the best first move which is
going to you know allow your pieces to
get into the game very very quickly if
if you are able to break in the center
with d5 so yeah 2d5 i think is probably
a very simple way to get your pieces in
the game but even after takes in knight
f3 it's it's not too late for black to
just kind of calm down a little bit and
get developed no need to go crazy with
with g5 but that's what he goes for we
get bishop to c4
and now queen to e7 so theodore's a
little bit afraid so he's going to
defend his f7 pawn
we get d4 by morphe
um d5 by black so you know maybe
theodore knight knows a little bit about
what he's doing he's like okay i'm up
material i just need to get my pieces in
the game and then i can succeed
um so i actually like this move d5 by
theodore knight we get bishop takes d5
and now i think black plays a pretty
unfortunate move so this obviously isn't
the move that loses the game pretty
tough to lose the game yet but from this
move onwards you sort of get the feeling
that that morphe is in control
so black to move here let's come up with
some some candidate moves probably
everything wins but there are a couple
moves that i like uh quite a bit better
than the rest
yeah go ahead um if you have some ideas
so c6 okay you played the move that
theodore knight played um
so not in bad company um so obviously
you know c6 black is still winning but
we'll see that that morphe is really
going to get the pieces flowing after
this move so we want to
kill the game dead in the game to make
sure we don't get embarrassed and lose
to somebody who gave us a full rook and
a night to start with
so there are a couple moves that are i
would call them game killers here where
there's just no no opportunity
for for white to really
really mess with us once we get these in
yeah knight f6 you know this move is
very desirable but you are playing with
a little bit of fire uh in terms of your
g5 pawn maybe maybe knight f6 is a good
move okay to be honest knight f6 wins c6
also wins everything wins because you
have broken a knight but
uh
so you're playing bishop
yeah so bishop e6 and what's what's the
justification behind it why can we play
this move
one of these pieces that could attack
you or something right okay you're
getting developed and you're threatening
to trade off one of your opponent's only
attacking pieces so
right because we've pressured down the e
file so what i meant the justification
why why aren't we worried about bishop
takes b7
it's just wrong
i mean yeah we are already up material
but giving back a full rook would be
kind of extensive yeah
or
desperate i don't know
but black has a tactic of course
yeah we do just have queen b4 and bishop
b7 is just unplayable due to this move
so
yeah so even though um
even though you know morphe is giving
the odds to the player with the black
pieces play with the black pieces could
still you know do some tactics right you
can't be so afraid of your opponent that
you're just like you know trying to uh
so the way that a lot of people lose
odds games is they they try to play the
safest move every move and as a result
they just start kind of playing
sub-optimal moves and if you play enough
of those eventually chances start to
come so bishop e6 i think um if black
had played this move you know
blunder's notwithstanding i i struggle
to see how morphy would ever even create
chances here it seems very very
difficult right once this bishop is gone
it seems very tough to do much with with
white
but instead c6 was played
and so i criticized this move a little
bit uh what do you think morphe had in
mind against c6
you're gonna have to play bishop takes
f7 i absolutely agree so
let's let's go get
em questionable so yeah black chose
queen takes maybe king takes was also
okay but right
now
so knight g5 i think is going to allow
black to
potentially play queen to g6
and then maybe someday
we will actually develop our pieces
it's a thing
it is a thing yeah
because the nine is holding the fourth
pawn
right so you know we might we might get
some material back in this line
right uh on these squares
but i would be more concerned about uh
the speed at which black is able to
develop here right right you know this
is threatens we we can defend it somehow
but
now i'm gonna go knight e7
i might even
shudder to think castle my king in this
game
but uh
morphe has has
yeah just it's it's this very similar
idea i'll just go ahead and show um
rather than knight g5 allowing the queen
to keep us boxed out he just goes knight
e5 you know he says this g-pawn doesn't
matter i'm already down a rook in a
night i i'm gonna go go for the kill so
95 i i think is the best practical try
and now this allows us just to develop
very fluidly out with with queen to h5
check
um
so you kind of get here by force after
c6 and so you go from a position where
you know you're up a rook at night for
for nothing to a position where you're
up a rook at a knight and a bishop but
now your king's on e7 and you're dealing
with these kinds kinds of threats
um
so the task now with morphe is to keep
it interesting how do we keep the attack
flowing and get more pieces involved
yeah um castle's king side i think is
uh
probably just as good as
what morphe played um so morphy throws
in this move h4 first so probably you
were intending to do something like this
or g3 after you cast
yeah so uh h4 first i think is is good
uh it also prevents black from playing
the natural move uh pawn to h6 because
while this rook is still here we still
have threads down the h file
so instead black goes g takes h4 now you
know mission accomplished we undermined
the f pawn so now we can cast
right
to his credit theodore knight continues
to try to hold it all together with
bishop h6 oh sorry
just needs to defend everything he's
he's got g4 covered so there's no night
fork
but now
morphy finds a way to to bring in the
final attackers
um how did the tactics work out i'll
just take back or maybe even reptics
black does have this covered and so
black is thrilled to trade off any any
defense or any attackers
the only thing i can see is like knight
back to
f3
okay you could come back let's let's
actually just pause for a moment and and
take some time so
as always in chess even when you're down
uh a rook and a piece and another piece
uh at some points it's useful to stop
and take this
uh i i don't know
i don't want to call it positional
approach but a useful question to always
ask yourself whether the position is
tactical or positional is uh how can i
improve my pieces
so wait a minute so go ahead just wait a
minute hold on to that thought i'm gonna
let everybody think for for a little bit
um and then and then we'll discuss so
how can i improve my pieces so white has
a lot of very very active pieces but
there are still improvements to be made
so that's where where morphe's morphe is
thinking here
so go ahead take some time and whenever
you've got it you can raise the hands
all right
what do you think alex
yeah b3 is absolutely what morphe played
so black hasn't stopped up on this f
file um
maybe we were looking at some ideas of
trying to attack this guy but you know
black has this uh pretty well covered so
we ask ourselves what's the worst piece
potentially this bishop on c1
conveniently this king rests on a dark
square diagonal so morphe plays b3 ready
to activate the bishop
um theodore knight continues his
resolute defense with knight to d7
of course we're going to bring the
bishop out now with check
and black tries
pawn to c5 so let's pause again
think about how we can improve our
pieces there's no knockout punch here
just yet
but uh
morphy just keeps improving to the
maximum until something cracks
and to his credit theodore knights
after c6 so far has defended
perfectly acceptably his
he is completely winning in this
position
okay so our queen is very active our
knight is very active our bishop is well
placed
that of course leaves this rook on f1 so
what can we do to activate this rook
on f1
yeah so we can uh there are two things
we could try we could try to open up the
f file somehow but i would agree that
this seems pretty difficult or we can
try to find a new file for it so the
question to ask yourself is which file
can can white try to force open in many
lines
yeah absolutely
that's uh something about morphe's odds
games that are somewhat surprising yes
it's often a beautiful tactical finish
but leading up to it there's all these
uh just nice positional moves he says
what's my worst piece where can i put it
and he finds the d1 square so uh first
was mentioned rook e1 yeah this move i i
don't fully see how
we're ever getting in with the rook
right this this e pawn is actually
pretty stable
not a lot of chances for it to move out
of the way but if we go to d1 of course
these pawns are already in tension and
opening up this diagonal is is
definitely something that that could
happen in the near future
uh and finally
theodore knight cracks under the
pressure so
give you a little whiplash we'll flip
the board here
um black to move there are uh there are
in fact still a number of ways to win
most moves are are still winning for
black
but let's see if you guys can find uh
not just a move but kind of a
two to three to four move plan how can
we complete development and and finally
shut down this initiative that that
white has
how do we untangle here
this is your chance your chance to beat
paul morphy
we've made it this far
so b6 is um
is one of the moves that win but but how
how are you following up like let's say
white actually captures on c5 after b6
um knight takes c5 knight takes e5
knight takes c5 yeah knight takes c5
okay so we'll go ahead and look at this
on the board
actually
you could actually
yeah you have to do that
yeah
knight e5 might might get you in a
little bit of trouble um
yeah so
i mean i agree that that black should be
should be winning here but i i also
think that maybe we haven't fully locked
things down right uh i'm
looking and seeing all kinds of ideas
maybe even something as crazy as uh
knight to f7 this this kind of idea
could could cause you problems when i'm
doubling up on on c5 and okay you're
taking my guys
but
you know again this is
not so comfortable for
for for black you're gonna have to do
some running
um
yeah maybe this one specifically doesn't
work but lots of ideas still
so b6 uh you know it does win but you
still have to be quite careful
i would say that there's
uh one move that kind of sticks out to
me as as being very very clean a very
nice solution for black
to
step out of a lot of these these nasty
nasty ideas
yeah absolutely um i think f8 is is the
cleanest way to continue so what are
some of the ideas why why does king f8
stick out to you
well because
g7 looks like a good hiding spot yeah so
we could potentially put this king onto
g7 um and i think even more importantly
um we're giving ourselves a lot more
options for how to deal with this
diagonal right we're gonna be able to
develop this night out um and once this
knight gets out and our king's on g7
then our rook is playing and once our
rook is playing then then then the rest
is kind of history so after king f8 here
i think morphy would be kind of in a bad
way there's still a lot of tactical
ideas you can try like um i would be
really reluctant to to capture on d7 but
let's just do it for example so we can
break through here just like you said g7
is going to be a nice hiding spot we
also have 97
and the pieces are are coming in once
the pieces are coming in
you know the material kind of speaks
speaks for itself so i think if it would
have been a really nice way to uh to
continue now
nobody in the in-person audience
suggested the losing move but someone
online did so uh
uh
so it's very very natural to want to do
what black did in this position black of
course captured
on e5 but this move loses the game so
i'll flip one more time
white to move and
you can't do win
you cannot do that so try to calculate
it all before
before we say anything
morphe has done it
okay what do you think
[Music]
yep and then uh what what what happens
on the various black options
right so you go to different places
what's these two moves have the same
problem right yeah yeah so what's that
so this is where our handy dandy rook
comes into play
pawn takes e5 check and hitting the
queen this is gonna be you know enough
material back
so you do have to play king to e6 so
i'll let you guys think from from this
position about bishop c5 king to e6
uh so if you go d5 i'll go king to d7
well the bishop
yes is bishop c5 king e6 right king e6
yes
right and then you take
pawn takes
knight
um
okay i mean i'll go
let me be
cautious here
yeah i will play
uh queen g6
i've interposed right so i'll go ahead
and put this on the board
um you can win my queen here
but i'm not so sure the queen's enough
anymore right like just for for example
uh takes takes
i have a lot of squares covered so you
probably need to come this way
come bishop e6
and at the end of the day
i have
two rooks a night and a bishop for the
queen
which is pretty good
um
obviously my king is still a bit weak
but i think black would be would be
winning pretty comfortably here so
something better
okay
any big ideas
okay we'll start shooting
back here
yeah thinking is that the queen is the
only thing protecting that knight if you
take pawn takes knight
then he can't retake with the queen
right so queen g6 is still probably
right but then you hit him with the
queen
yeah i think we're transposing all right
yeah so so still here you can you can
pick up the queen but yeah we transpose
not quite enough
so yeah bishop c5 king e6 is right
and then alex
yeah queen e8 check is the is the
knockout punch here and the game does
actually finish knight e7
d5
and there is nowhere left to run for
this king i was thinking
um
black could have tried queen e7
but now we are actually getting quite a
bit of material i think maybe there's
more forcing i can give check first and
then check
and then check
and
it
takes maybe i haven't done the most
convincing job here either
hmm queen e7
okay maybe i should do this
yeah probably i should do this
and then take
and all your stuff is is just still
hanging
and white is winning
take here next go here and here
all good stuff
but theodore knight didn't even try just
went qui 97 allowed for d5 um
so this is kind of the quintessential
early you know
early chess history kind of odds games
that you would see they actually look a
lot like early games without odds where
white goes crazy and sacrifices
something and then you know black takes
all the material and then gets
checkmated that's the these are all the
games that that have been written down
from from old history
uh so i wanted to move on to one that
did not go so well for the odds giver
um it's a very interesting game because
uh capablanca is playing
but compa blocka is being given odds how
does this make any sense who does this
ramon iglesias guy think he is giving
capablanca odds
so uh there's a twist to this game but
maybe we should just look look at the
game first so
this one capablanca kind of just puts on
a clinic here we get knight f3 we get
the petrov
and i really don't like this move by by
ramon iglesias the the odds giver um
it's going to open up the e file and
sort of lead to
uh
kinds of positions where
you know it's not going to be very very
complex you're going to have a
symmetrical structure there's going to
be one open file on the board
capablanca is going to be able to use
the major pieces as as we'll see
so i would have preferred to see
something a lot more closed even
something like d3 just just keep it
locked down keep chances alive uh
instead we get this
um rather funnily uh kappa blanca just
reply responds with knight takes e4 so
what's normally the problem with this
line
yeah normally white goes queen e2 and
black's in a little bit of trouble uh
but queen e2 is illegal here uh unlucky
uh so here white just goes d4 kappa
blanca does follow up with d6 and bishop
e7 so pretty stark difference compared
to last game cappa blanca is playing
simple chess developing his pieces
keeping his pieces on defended squares
we get c4 kappa block of castles knight
c3 knight c6 a3 a6 bishop d2
now a slightly weird move b6 by by
cappablanca uh white goes ahead and
castles we get bishop to d7 now
and yeah okay i don't know what this b6
move is all about but that's fine
everything else he's been doing is great
king to b1
and knight a5
so uh i like this method of playing by
by cavablanca as well like you could
theoretically go much slower rookie 8
maybe bishop f8 just try to play on the
e file but your opponent is castled
queenside you're castled king's side
even though you're up a lot of material
doesn't mean you should just throw away
all the chess principles you know you
should come after this king on the queen
side that's exactly what what kappa
blanca does so net a5 rook c1
knight b3
attacks two things and then bam c5 so
not in a rush to trade his good pieces
for white's bad pieces
even though he's up a ton of material
just breaks with with c5 and tries to
activate the rest of his his forces here
d5 rookie 8 does get played h4 and then
b5 just very simple chess
opponent's king is here we have a queen
he doesn't we're going to attack and our
attack's going to be better because we
have a queen
g4
knight to d4
is a very good practical move trying to
induce knight takes d4 which does get
played and now of course following this
uh the open c file is going to be
difficult for for white to d to deal
with uh we get bc4 and f6 bishop f6
bishop c4 cavablanca says you hung upon
i don't care
fair enough
uh bishop d3 bishop f3 or h3 kappa
blanca says i will keep taking your
pawns no way do you checkmate me here
h5 bishop b6 g3 g6 f4
bishop h4 rook g1
okay
and i sort of blitzed through this game
because honestly there's not much to
talk about capablanco was up a queen he
developed all his pieces and and now
he's winning
uh so here
uh obviously white is trying to break
through on g6 so let's find a couple
good defensive moves for capablanca this
game and then we can we can wrap up
uh kappa blocka's adventure here so how
do we deal with white's threats to our
g6 pawn and of course behind that pawn
are king
it's really the first time
white has posed any kind of problem to
black at all
before this it sort of just seemed like
black was maybe the one who should have
been giving the odds
yeah alex
g6 g5
oh that's an interesting one okay so
uh anticipating that white is going to
try to break things open with something
like f5 we should definitely keep this
g5 idea in mind um that being said
if we do it immediately while this pawn
is still in f4 i think that perhaps this
is not not going to work out quite as
cleanly as we want g6 is still going to
be able to open things up of course the
idea of g5 would be to prevent the
g-file from from opening but
for example you know i think a move like
bishop d5 would be perfectly fine
preparing to meet something like f5 with
with g5 this would make uh quite a bit
of sense
um but even even simpler by capoblanca
than either of these ideas
now let's pretend there's a queen on c1
right and so we we have something we're
actually afraid of um what what would we
do if it were
a more realistic position to defend our
king
i assume you
yeah no i it's just all the normal
natural defensive moves so king h8 comes
to mind i think that might be the one
that that capoblanca chose
um yeah he does play king h8 here
i was also just going to mention you
know a simple simple chess play
something like queen f6 defend your g6
pawn
try to regain control over the light
squares uh all just very very normal
moves are are all you need here because
you're up a queen
um so king h8 and of course like
following up we have ideas of coming to
rick g8 we're just going to contest this
open file and we will be doing well so
f5 cap blank is not afraid we get a
trade he says sure i'm fighting back on
this file now and you just have
absolutely nothing so king h8 rook g8
very common defensive idea works even
better when you're up a queen okay so
rick g2 takes takes queen f6 and this
game is over um ramona iglesias resigns
against jose raul capoblanca so what's
the catch who is this random guy giving
queen odds to capablanca does anyone
know has anyone heard of this game
nope uh real players the real jose roble
capablanca it's just that he was uh
playing this game in 1893
which if you know anything about
capablanca that would make him four
years old so this is toddler capablanca
absolutely crushing ramona iglesias uh
you know he did have queen odds but he
also kind of just outplayed on the
entire game
so even at four years old cappa blanca
knew a thing or two about how to develop
pieces and uh and fight back yeah alex
that's the story uh maybe it's a little
apocryphal uh but uh yeah the story
behind this game iglesias cavablanca
cavablanca was four years and 10 months
so nearly five so i mean yeah
now now who cares
um yeah i mean i didn't do
in-depth research to see if this story
was a little apocryphal but um it's a
fun story kappa block of four years old
just crushing it i'm really not sure
who could play better with black yeah no
he i i would say this was a very very
strong chess game uh
again
b6 just doesn't make a lot of sense
everything else he did
really did make a lot of sense could
argue maybe he should be playing d5 in
this structure d5 makes more sense than
whatever this b6 bishop d7 thing is
but yeah knight a5 to b3 followed by c5
in knight d4 is pretty high level stuff
i don't know what all that was about
for a four-year-old
all right should we check should we
check
let's let's see
let's see
uh nope d5 knight a5 best moves
sometimes sometimes lucky also knight b8
best stock fish move there you go bishop
g4
b6 um is worse by a full point three
yeah much much much worse 0.3 yeah
okay
so that's what odds games looked like in
the 1800s so you have the morphe game um
i skipped over a steiner's game where it
basically the same thing happened white
sacrificed all the pieces and won by
checkmate so surely in the year 2020
things things are going to be different
right things are going to be different
humans came a long way in chess we've
got our hero hikaru nakamura manning the
black pieces against the villain
komodo the chess engine so
these days odds games have not really
been in in favor you don't see a lot of
exhibitions with grand masters giving
like crazy odds or something uh it's
just not quite as interesting as some
some other things i think
but this is still a fun way uh to level
the playing field a little bit against
computers so i wanted to take a look at
um this match that hikaru had against
play komodo
the match did not go so well for him i
think this was in the fall of 2020
um
so throughout the match hikaru was given
various kinds of of two pawns up uh
handicaps so here you see the f pawns
and the c pawns are missing
and uh it's kind of interesting i want
to see how komodo is able to just out
calculate hikaru
in about uh 10 moves
just 10 moves is all it takes from down
two pawns to to significantly better
so let's take a look um komodo starts
with e4 developing pieces e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 bishop
bishop c5
so white to move here we already have a
number of problems to solve with with
the white pieces we're kind of in
trouble
so wait to move how do we finish
development in this position
our opponent has made castling illegal
highly unfortunate for us
we have all these pieces that need to
get into the game
what can we do
we have no c pawn to support our center
it's all very very sad
g4 would be a lot
d4 that makes a lot more sense so what's
so good about d4
okay so of course you know it's
activating our bishop along this
diagonal i agree but even more
importantly perhaps it's interfering
with uh this this bishop along this
diagonal it's going to give us a lot a
lot better chance to uh finish
development now i think this is you know
this move by hikaru is technically
correct it's a fine move but i think
this is probably his worst move of the
game practically speaking
if you go bishop takes d4 here
white still cannot castle and the worst
thing that happens to you is this gets
traded for this and then you can finish
development
um however he goes knight takes d4
so now komodo to move and look like paul
morphy
yep go ahead
yeah just like in the 1800s people are
still losing chess games to bishop takes
f7 and knight takes e5
um
so black
has
only one move to still be okay here
um which is king to e7
um not so natural to do this with your
pieces when there's a bishop here but
your knight is going to cover this
square well enough in the short term and
if you play like a computer then you are
just uh you're going to survive and you
can be minus like two
hooray uh instead hikaru plays king to
f8 and so
let's go ahead and play like komodo uh
wait to move what's the natural
follow-up
you just castle with check pretty good
knight to f6
and now komodo plays a move that that is
maybe not so natural but
uh it's a move that both solves problems
for white and creates threats against
the black position
so we've got some problems of our own
right you know this is here
this knight is active we're down a piece
we're down a couple pawns still well
just one pawn now
so we need some way to
keep the pieces flowing
because if you take your time here
uh black will eventually develop his
pieces right i don't know d-pawn
somewhere
bishop out
uh
really unclear how these two pieces are
ever gonna gonna get back in the game
but still also i think
our laptop might not be plugged in then
i'm plugged in on my end so it'd be
downstairs
um b4
yeah
okay
so there are a lot of double checks
available
um
i like the move b4
but we can actually do the same idea
while creating another thread so
maybe b4 is is reasonable but i mean
let's just say bishop b6
yeah
knight c4 maybe i go knight
e2 honestly it looks similar to the main
line but
you kind of have this idea just
immediately
looking good now then um
so rather than knight c4 uh
i i think it is quite nice to attack
this bishop because if you go knight c4
maybe like check so you go knight d3
um and the point is now these kinds of
moves are no longer so scary because we
are attacking this bishop and so our
rook will not die
um
and also what's the other threat that
we're making with knight to d3
yeah we're threatening e5 so we get to
do both both things at once
um b4 probably is just like a slightly
worse version of this maybe you'll get
what we had in the game which is knight
to e2 check and knight takes c1
um although here
still this this looks quite quite good
for for white
uh
yeah okay this this piece hanging is is
a much bigger problem actually yeah yeah
this is not going to be enough we just
go d6
we're blockading we're activating black
is is crushing it
um so knight to d3 targets this bishop
doesn't allow for these discovered
checks black of course does still have
this double check can't take the bishop
because the knight attacks the king but
we just go king h1
and after knight takes c1 we go knight
takes c5 this knight is trapped
and white is regaining the piece plus
we're castled plus black black's
position looks like this and this is now
plenty of compensation for all of one
pawn
uh so how long did that take ten moves
yeah ten moves and white is uh winning
so that's how long you you know hikaru
nakamura could last against placimoto in
this game
so to follow up uh hikaru tries queen to
e7 queen takes c1 of course
now d6
we're gonna retreat
uh came to g8 to unpin the uh the knight
from the king
just knight to c3
hikaru you know
rather smartly does not go pawn hunting
here you just need to develop your
pieces um
knight to e4
you know there's there's a lot of things
that white can do probably just queen to
e3 is winning the game
so bishop b6 e5 of course we just want
to open things up takes takes
queen c5 queen e1
rec f8 queen g3
knight h5
check
queen e3
and after queen to c5 uh hikaru had
actually just seen enough and went ahead
and resigned
um kind of zoomed through the end of
that game there uh part of that is
because
the computer's moves might not be the
most intuitive but the intuitive moves
also win in these positions it's just
that komodo is like calculating a ton
and so it can kind of do whatever it
wants because it knows it sees all the
tricks um in this position why did
hikaru resign i think because queen to
e7 is a rather difficult threat to stop
also white can just pick up all of these
bonds over here and there's just not not
much you can do with with black or d1 to
d8 or
i believe that was a different odds
match i don't think this would happen if
the car who had access to rivka
to my memory he did yeah so uh julian in
the class is talking about uh there was
another odds match of this kind where i
think karu had access to another chess
engine he said ripka that could be it um
but i don't know the details so look
that one up at your own risk
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
this game and compare this match that
hikaru had against play komodo again
hikaru didn't get swept i think he had
three draws out of the match i think he
lost one and a half to six and a half
so three draws and five losses
um
what's the difference between this match
where white is giving up two pawns
versus another match we're going to look
at where uh the same engine komodo was
giving full piece odds to actually a
significantly weaker grand master than
than nakamura and so to look at that i
wanted to look at this real chess
position i know there's a first for
everything on the road to 2000 a real
chess position
uh so let's follow along with that
hikaru game
we got bishop c4 bishop c5 now
hypothetically in real chess if black if
white tries what white tried in the game
against ikaru
um
somewhat counterintuitively king f8 best
move
and with these two pawns on the board
black is completely winning with these
two pawns off the board white is uh
doing quite quite well
um and so this is i think the huge
downside that hikaru had in his match
that maybe went a little bit unnoticed
the opening patterns the patterns that
are ingrained into these people's
memories are just gonna be wrong um
pawns are missing files are open
diagonals are open it's uh potentially
even weirder than like chess 960 which
already you know messes up these these
top grandmasters and so i think hikaru
was was falling victim to this quite a
bit and that's why you see moves like
the last one whereby move 10 doesn't
matter that hikaru started with two
extra pawns he's just dead lost
um
because here king f8 by far the best
move and it's like minus three um here
king f8 very bad move it's like uh
plus one
which you know is fatal against a
computer
uh with that in mind i do want to move
on to this other match so this time our
hero and we will look from the heroes
side is david smearden uh up against
play komodo so uh rather than hikaru's
odds which were you know the f pawn in
the c pawn in other matches it was the f
pawn and the b pawn
they sort of moved around which pawns it
was this time komodo is starting without
the king's knight
and the way that smirdon handles this
game is pretty indicative of how this
entire match went he played a six game
match against komodo he won five of them
um without too much difficulty there was
some grinding he had to do in a couple
end games and he lost one game because
he made a very simple blunder because
he's a human
aren't we all
um in this game we get d4 e6 e4 d5 so i
wanted to ask what you guys thought of
this choice by david smirdon he's
playing an odds game against a chess
engine
he chooses the french defense is this a
good idea or a bad idea i've told you
the results of the match so you might
already know what i think but
what's going on with the
i french like it yeah julian doesn't
like it
yeah so this is like the the normal line
of thinking for
uh odds givers and odds receivers if
you've been given odds it makes sense to
open the position we talked about in
that kappa blanca game i didn't like
white's decision to open the e-file
early on uh just allowing for for
simpler play
and the french
is going to allow white to steer the
game into more closed positions where
it's going to be more difficult
to trade pieces um so that is the big
argument against choosing the french now
we'll see that maybe smeared on had some
idea of what he was doing though does
anyone have a different take yeah
because you alex back even when as far
as playing deep junior
they wanted to close the position
because they thought computers weren't
going to close position right not good
at maneuvering so that's probably where
marion was thinking was he's not
okay so i have a different take than
everyone here so what alex just said is
the you know the
late 90s early 2000s way of thinking
which is these computers are great at
tactics and great at calculating but in
the slower closed types of positions
where the chess kind of revolves around
plans and pawn breaks um computers were
lagging behind for for some number of
years
now i i honestly don't think that that's
true at all in in present chess um but i
think what smearden did is is not so
ridiculous so let's take a look at a few
more moves this game we saw knight c3
knight f6 e5 knight fd7 uh f4
c5 so what smeared in has done is i
believe his line of thinking is he's
chosen an opening where the king's
knight is a very very important piece
for applying pressure early on
um
you know you see this knight come to f3
see this knight threatened to come to g5
and like checkmate checkmate to black
you also see this knight come to f3
where it's very very necessary to
control the d4 pawn
and that is the huge gap in white's
position for for playing the french um
without this knight able to support this
pawn um you see the the engine
immediately say i i can't support this
pawn on d4 i'm gonna take on c5 try
something more normal like knight to e2
um
either yeah i think probably takes right
away
and we are actually going to get more
peace trades than you would expect from
a closed position in the french like
okay you can obviously keep pieces on
the board
but you're running quite a bit of risk
um you know moving around so much
so i'm curious
i'm open to descent here but i think
that's where david smearden was coming
from uh what do you think julian do you
still
sort of surprised that the computer went
for this option like i would have
thought it would go e5 right away
just to keep things like locked you know
yeah like uh knight c3 it also like ic3
is weird because it also lets black go d
e
yeah so this is potentially also a fault
in the the programming of play komodo so
um
to my knowledge i don't think they
tweaked too much of the engine's
settings to to make this play like give
odds better um i think they were just
saying yeah this is komodo beat komodo
with an extra knight
so
you're totally right though because the
advance just isn't playable anymore you
go knight c6 quick v6
this is well this as well and i think
this is what david had in mind if you if
you play the advance
black is going to win your d-pawn um
because you have no king side knight so
potentially very counter-intuitive
approach by by david going for an
opening like like the french but
you kind of need this piece in the
french that this is what i was thinking
um
so here you see the engine just take on
c5
and after uh knight c6 a3 now black
takes on c5 and david does start to take
this kind of approach where he's like
i'm gonna open the position at all costs
we're gonna trade pieces and i i will
have more pieces than my opponent so
very responsible way of playing now it
takes takes
and your note on being surprised that
the engine went for
um this knight c3 line
here i really think this is where komodo
could have benefited greatly from just
one or two tweaks in the programming
there is really no objective reason why
you shouldn't play a move like queen e2
here with white you're down a full piece
you should keep the queen on the board
komodo just takes on d8 and we as humans
i i don't know a single like you know
human who who plays a lot of chess who
would take on d8 here and just be like
yeah i'm down a piece but this is
probably the best i can do like you want
to keep the queen on the board you want
to take your material back you want to
you know try try to get your opponent
right so queen takes d8 not not such a
great uh try from komodo and then from
here uh it's just very very clean play
by by smearing
he gets his king to a reasonable
position he develops his pieces and then
he just starts playing with an extra
piece he says yeah
let's trade light square bishops i'll
develop
he says yeah
i'll get my pieces in the game
goes e5 knight e6
and here he has to maneuver some tricks
but he says okay you want to win my f7
pawn win my f7 pawn i don't care i'm i'm
up a piece as long as we're getting
another piece off the board sure
takes on f7 we get rook g6
and now he's a grandmaster and he has an
extra piece he repeats for some time
takes f6
brings his knight around to a more
active position
repeats for time
repeats for time takes the b5 pawn
brings the knight around again takes the
c5 pawn
and now he starts to push
brings in the king
and now it's just gonna be checkmate
and that is the end of the game
so maybe there's hope for for humans yet
you know these these weird two pawns
positions i think are deceptively quite
difficult for for humans to play
objectively it is still massive odds a
computer would be another computer from
that position i i think close to 100 if
not 100 of the time
but as as humans we were very reliant on
these patterns
and uh you know given time to prep as as
david was for this match he was able to
kind of realize hey all these patterns
in the french were black attacks d4 you
know kind of in every single line ever
white needs to play knight f3 or knight
e2 and defend the d-pawn and now all of
a sudden that's illegal
so david is is able to use these
patterns that chess players are familiar
with that humans are good at to to his
advantage very effectively and so that's
a huge credit i think to to him in this
match and clearly his strategy worked
out uh winning five of the six games
um okay so i think that is sort of where
i'm gonna call it for the night do you
guys have any questions for me about
odds games or any of the lessons were
taken away
okay excellent hopefully you guys
enjoyed uh just a brief recap uh
the the one thing that i would say to
take away from from these games uh
in your own chess games obviously you
can apply some principles to when you're
up a massive amount of material but
really
at its heart chess is a game about
improving your pieces we saw that in the
morphe game morphe every turn improves
his pieces makes it tricky and even in
these other games you see everybody just
fighting to make their pieces better
whether or not they're up two pawns or
up at night to start with or they're the
ones giving their odds it's all about
improving your pieces
to the maximum
okay if you're watching online please do
stay tuned we'll have grand master el
shawn moradiabody coming in to teach the
next class running from 7 30 to 8 30
and that should be in just a couple
minutes um as always my name is caleb
denby thank you very much for joining me
on the road to 2000 and i will see you
next monday
thanks
[Music]
you